hello everybody let's get started right
now so we are from here maps we are a
mapping and location services company my
name is Dylan Babs I'm from Seattle and
I work in our developer relations group
and I'm here with two of my colleagues
from Berlin over here we have Ignacio he
is the engineering manager for HAARP GL
and then over here we have Nino who is
also an engineer for HAARP GL so a
little bit about our company I like to
say we're a full-stack mapping company
so we do everything from collecting data
we have people all over the world in
local offices driving our own cars kind
of like what you see for Street View
cars collecting data that is then
compiled into our global map which she
didn't consume in many different ways
one of them being HAARP GL which we'll
talk about later today but you could
also see our Maps in places like
navigation systems so in North America
and Europe four out of five cars will
have our Maps in their navigation
systems and we're collecting a ton of
data nearly 28 terabytes daily and in
our cars that are collecting lidar we're
doing 700,000 points of data per second
and we're not just doing standard
mapping we also have some HD maps so
that could be maps for autonomous
vehicles and we've so far covered
600,000 kilometers for autonomous
driving maps so really all different
sorts of mapping but today we'll be
talking about our new JavaScript product
which is called HAARP GL it's a 3d map
web renderer so this is going to be a
library they could put on your web sites
display some really rich and custom 3d
maps so harp CL has a couple key
concepts
three that we wanted to build it on the
first is modern web tech so we built it
on WebGL for really fast and performant
rendering so it's works with all modern
browsers
sometimes the exception of Internet
Explorer the second principle we wanted
to build on was open source we really
value community contributions and it's
really nice to have the community in
mind when actually building this product
so during the workshop today if you have
any
ideas or bug reports and such we highly
encourage you to create either a pull
request or an issue on github that way
we could really take your feedback into
consideration for the next release then
finally third principle we wanted to
build harp chiel on was the flexibility
and interoperability so by this we mean
two things one is that you could choose
any data source that you want to put
into harp GL
like I said before we create our own
data sources that you could use but
you're not limited to just using us in
fact you could use some of our
competitor data sources like map box
ESRI TomTom you're free to really mix
and match harp GL with whatever you want
because it's open source you're able to
do that and the second is not just data
source but also data type will be
providing vector tiles which is a way to
consume the map data but really you
could put on any type of data source or
type that you want in there since it's
built upon 3j s you could put any type
of 3d object in there as well and so we
made harp GL for a couple of reasons the
first is we have a product out there
called open location platform this is
something if you're like EMW Daimler and
you're creating data pipelines of your
cars around the world ingestion sensor
data since your data is basically the
data that a car is collecting as it
drives maybe like the width from the
road
how far can see and such this is a
pipeline you could create to actually
collect that data and view it online and
then so you actually need a lot of 3d
use cases for this type of stuff the
second use case was High Definition Maps
when I mentioned earlier in the
presentation this is really important
because you need visualization of
different Z levels like say for example
this bridge right here excuse me you
need to actually be able to distinguish
what is below and what above so 3d
visualization can provide some very
powerful debugging tools for this and
then finally we have a new product
coming out called here navigation on
demand which is really a modern take on
these navigation systems and cars using
modern technology before a lot of it was
native os's that you put inside the
vehicle but now we're trying to
experiment with maybe web views and such
so since harp CL is a web product you're
able to do that
it's a really flexible technical
architecture when it comes to in vehicle
infotainment and navigation systems so
today we'll be doing a workshop you'll
be learning how to implement a bunch of
different 3d web mapping situations and
different features so let's go ahead and
enter this link into your browser and
that will take you to a github workshop
so that's bitly slash Jas comp
- harp so this repo we have is called
Deb rail workshops and we have a
director in here called harp GL which
links you directly to it we also have a
bunch of other of our developer API
workshops in here as well
so if you enjoyed this product and you
want to learn more about some of our
other company's offerings feel free to
browse around in here so some prereqs
for this workshop you just need a laptop
with a modern web browser which I'm sure
you all have in that node and NPM or
yarn installed so in this workshop we
also have a few different resources
listed here we have the github repo
which you could find all the open source
code for our we have a link to the
documentation which has all the
information on the different classes
objects and methods and then we have the
live examples which is right over here
these are pretty helpful because you
click around use some different features
you can implement like the globe right
here but then you could also click view
source over here on the bottom right and
I'll take you directly to the code
needed to run that example so did anyone
have trouble reaching the workshop link
oops produces you should show that
no they Qasim
great so feel free to read ahead in the
workshop for the next like 10 minutes or
so I'm gonna be explaining some key
concepts but if I'm going too slow and
you want to be faster you're welcome to
just read through the workshop so in
harp the high level object is called a
map view this is gonna be the object
that are gonna be modifying and adding
things to inside your map so say for
example you want to initialize a new map
you could just do harp equals new harp
dot map view you could pass it the
canvas that's going to be the HTML
element on your page that you want to
put the map in then you could also
assign a theme we have a couple
different themes available which you
could use for example like normal day
light and dark and you could also create
your custom themes which we'll be doing
later on in the workshop and then you
could also choose a projection which
we'll talk about a little bit more later
so there's a very popular type of
geographic data formats for the web it's
called geo JSON have any of you guys
heard of geo JSON before it's pretty
easy to work with mostly because it's
just JSON so nice for web development
and heart GL uses many different types
of geo JSON but there's two examples I'd
like to point out here just to get you
guys familiar with a type a point in a
line so if we take a look at the
structure of geo JSON you have the type
which is mostly always going to be a
feature and then you have geometry this
is where you classify which type of
geometry will be it could be a point it
could be a line it could be a polygon or
Multi polygon and then you could put the
coordinates and then there's also an
object in here called properties and
this is where you could really assign
any type of other properties you want to
it for example we could say the name of
it really anything you want to put in
there and then a line is pretty much the
same thing the only difference is the
type now says line string in here and
then coordinates is now no longer just
one array it's an array with arrays of
coordinates inside of it so you'll be
using geo JSON later on in this workshop
to actually put data on to the map and
geo JSON is nice because it's pretty
widely supported so a lot of websites
for open data will have geo JSON you get
download
and then another key concept we have is
our styling syntax and also styling
sheets because harp GL is a vector
render that means we're calling the data
from a server and then we're rendering
on the client we need to actually bind
style rules to it so say for example
you're looking at a map a lot of time
roads are yellow the waters blue that's
because there's style rules defined for
each type of property so say for example
here we're saying when the geometry type
is a point we want to use the technique
of circles so we want to draw circles
and then we want to make it this color I
have no idea what the 70d color is but
you could really assign any CSS value in
here you like and then size could also
be meters points or whatever you could
also clarify the metric in the unit for
this and then say for example for a
polygon pretty much the same thing we're
just saying when geometry type equals
polygons we want to apply these styling
rules I don't have an example of it in
here as well but you'd also style the
same properties you saw back here in the
point so say we want to say when we see
the dinner gap Islands we want to make
it yellow we would do when geometry I'm
sorry when property equals name and
Dinnigan islands we would apply the
certain style there so with maps many
you are probably familiar with the
Mercator projection also known as the
flat earth that's here on the left it's
a pretty standard map you see on web
maps it's pretty common and I think
people are used to it so we'd like to
see it but technically Mercator
projections aren't too accurate because
the top and the bottom are slightly
stretched out because you're projecting
a sphere into a rectangle so to show you
a cool example of this there is a fun
little web site called the true size
that I like to show everyone and play
around with we can see we're taking the
United States in the normal position
right here and if we drag it up to
Greenland we actually see that it gets
distorted I'm Ehren sorry I moved around
and grown much more so for example
Greenland isn't actually that size it's
definitely much smaller if you drag it
around here so this is why we've also
included a globe projection because it's
technically a more accurate view of the
world the world is a spear so
it's nice to be able to represent it as
a sphere in our Maps so you'll have the
option of doing two different types of
objections the Mercator and globe with
harp GL and you try them both out in the
workshop and then for data sources I
already mentioned vector tiles this is
when the data is being delivered from
the server and you're running on the
client it's really an optimized version
of Geo JSON but then you also have
static to your JSON say if you just want
to make a normal fetch request or a
network request to a static geo JSON
file you have in your local directory or
another site you could put that on to
your map as well but we also support
raster tiles so this is a great example
of doing satellite imagery a raster tile
is basically just a smaller image and
then for those of you familiar with 3j s
or other 3d objects you could also put
3d objects onto the map and then since
it's open source you were able to extend
harped GL however you want to add any
type of data source you would like then
in terms of consuming the API we have
two different ways one is a pretty
modern version with modules that you
install via NPM in the arm but we also
have a simple scripting API that you
could add and be a script tag on your
HTML this is sometimes easier and we'll
be using a simple bundle in the workshop
just because it'll get you started
easier if you're doing the modules those
were great because you could work on
with typescript and you really import
which ones you want at the time but
sometimes a little frustrating just to
get started with it because you have to
fight with web pack to get the right
configuration and such so today we'll be
doing the scripting API awesome so those
are the key concepts for Harpe GL
hopefully that background information
will help you out during the workshop so
the first thing we want to do is head on
over to our developer portal we have a
link in the workshop we scroll down past
the key concepts it will be developer
here comm slash events / J's comp aja 19
so in order to use harp seal you'll need
to sign up
on this site and this will give you
access to data and the reason we have a
special URL right here it just helps
with our tracking purposes and make sure
you get to the right key so you can use
it with HAARP CL so we'll give everyone
three to five minutes to go and sign up
online it's pretty simple click on it
click get started for free no credit
card or anything is required you only
just put in your name your country or
email and a password so go ahead and
click this right here and yeah once you
sign up feel free to take a look around
our developer portal and see some of the
other map services we have we offer
250,000 transactions a month for free
which is pretty generous when comparing
it against our competitors in the free
tier so 250,000 transactions is enough
to keep a small start-up floating
monthly
and feel free to raise your hand if you
have any questions we'll be happy to
come around and help
all right awesome how many of you have
signed up cool give it maybe just one
more minute
great so once you've signed up we have
one more small step to do to get
credentials if you go back to github
repository right below the navigate to
developer gear comm link you'll see text
that says once you've created a
developer account
navigate to the here XYZ token manager
so here XYZ is another one of our here
products that's actually serving us the
data so this is where we'll get our
token so I'll go ahead and click on this
link and I'll see this little modal here
and I'll sign in with the developer
account I just created about a minute
ago
and then once I've logged into the token
manager I could either generate a new
token which I'm sure I will be the case
for you guys since you're a first-time
user or I can manage the tokens but I'll
I'll generate a new token I'm gonna say
token for harp GL workshop I click
generate now I need to actually select
some rights and then we have a new token
up here generated so I'd keep this
window open because you'll be copying
and pasting this token later on into
your code or save it to a notepad or
something like that um is anyone having
issues with the token manager or any
confusion on how to get there
alright awesome let's go ahead and start
installing harp GL so I'm in section one
of the workshop and like I mentioned
before there's two methods of installing
harp GL one is linking the script bundle
into your HTML or you have the option of
installing the heartbeat riyals 3 NPM I
recommend for this workshop you do the
single script tag just for the sake of
simplicity so I'm gonna open up my
terminal and I'm going to create a new
directory I'm gonna call it harp - map
and then I'm going to except she make my
terminal little bit bigger is that big
enough for everybody and I'm going to CD
into that directory where I'm going to
create two files and index dot HTML and
then also an index dot JSON XJS files
where we will put all of our code for
our GL then you can open up that
directory with your favorite code editor
so I'll drag that folder into vs code
and then for the HTML you can go ahead
and copy and paste what we have right
here into our index.html and what we're
doing here is send up a style so putting
a zero border margin and padding on the
web site so we don't have any weird
borders or scrolling issues and then
also creating a canvas with the ID of a
map so I'm setting that to 100% of the
screen with the Handy 100 V H and B W
and then we also are adding to script
tags from unpackaged one is going to be
3 J s because we have a dependency on
that and then also the second will be
harp GL and then we also have another
script in here called extras j s
that's because there's gonna be some
extra 3d loading functions that we'll
need to add in later on up to put in 3d
objects so for this extra file its
included inside the dev'reaux workshops
resources file I'm sorry resources
folder so you click in there you'll see
that extras J s is right here you can
open the file click raw and then just do
file save page as into the heart map
directory
and then of course we're also linking to
our local index J s file will we be
writing the harp code so now I'll go
ahead and start pasting some stuff into
index J s the first is we're going to be
selecting the canvas so just using the
Dom get element by ID just like the map
and we'll be passing that into our harp
map view constructor so this just
writing canvas is an easier way of
saying canvas it's the same as canvas so
that might be a little bit easier and
then we're also linking a theme file
that is currently hosted on unpackage so
we have just a night a nice dark theme
and then we have two other parameters
max visible data source tiles and tile
cache size
those aren't required at first but they
help with some caching to make sure all
the tiles aren't reloading when they're
in the map view and the next thing we
want to do is set the camera location
and zoom so this takes two items in this
function the first we're going to be
passing it geo-coordinates object so
this is latitude 1.27 and longitude 103
and this is actually the coordinates for
Singapore so it's a format latitude
comma longitude and then also we're
setting a zoom level of 16 there's a
geospatial standard for zoom levels
between 1 and 20 where 20 is when you're
really zoomed in so 20 you'll be able to
see the street right in front of you
while 16 is about a nice view to have
like the city buildings and such visible
if you do zooms 1 or 2 you'll have the
whole earth visible
next I'm going to paste some map
controls he's basically helped with the
pointer event so you could drag around
the map and then also add some zoom
buttons on the right hand side and then
I'm also setting a max pitch angle and
then also rotation so since harp GL is a
3d engine you could set the angle of
what you're viewing this is between 0
and 90 or a0 is looking straight down
and the 90 would be my point of view so
if you want to set the camera from say
someone walking or driving on the street
do exactly what they say I started to
exactly what they'd see we would use 90
and then also set rotation this takes
the pitch and the rotation so if you
want to rotate the map this is what
you'd use and then we'll also just
include some code to make sure the map
changes sizes when you resize the window
and then finally the most important part
is we want to actually add some data to
our map so we're creating an object
called an OMB datasource V stands for
optimized map for visualization which is
basically a term were using for the data
the part of the map here's where you put
the base URL so as you saw we just
signed up for a service called here X Y
Z we see the X Y is the URL here and
then we pass the different API format
and then also the style set name and
then finally you could take that token
that you created in the XYZ token
manager and paste that into your XYZ
token here so I'm gonna go ahead and go
back to my token manager copy this paste
it here
and then to make sure we can see our map
I'm also going to want to set up a
simple local server so Python ahem
simple HTTP server and then your
favorite port number I'm going to use
eight eight eight eight and then in the
browser we can go to that localhost and
we'll see a dark map of Singapore has
appeared yeah yes of course it is bitly
/ JS comp - harp and then once you have
your map you could go ahead and drag it
around also change the pitch in the
bearing I'm doing this with two fingers
on my trackpad moving it up and down but
if you have a mouse or some other sort
of trackpad it's usually right click and
drag any questions on this step
we'll give it a few minutes make sure
everyone gets their map up and running
do you guys maybe want to walk around
see if there's any questions
so two fingers and drag you have to yeah
any questions over here questions
perfect looks like yeah oh yeah a strong
yes so to download it first I'll show
you where to get it
I mean yes to scroll to the top you'll
see a folder in here called resources so
just click on that and download that
file so what this is is it helps with
some 3d object loaders so some of them
are extensions of the three J's library
to import what we call FBX objects let's
talk about that later on and then also
is a quick little bug fix that we have
for globe Patrol so we had a release
that that didn't include it and we need
it for this workshop alright awesome you
guys having fun rotating your map and
moving around and such
yeah yeah of course yeah I'll show you
guys how to view the documentation as
well so up at the top in the resources
section we have some of the links like
to the repo Docs examples I'm gonna
click on Doc's right here and that's
going to take us to our documentation
page so we have a set of modules out
here on the right with the simple API
these are actually all combined into one
so it may be a little bit tricky to
figure out which one you're using with a
simple API but for map view it's named
the same we could see harp - map view on
the right hand side we'll click on that
and then inside this module you could
see some of the classes so there is a
class called map view within the module
map view so this is when you'll find all
the properties the getters and setters
and such for the module
awesome so now that we have a map up and
running let's do some modifications to
map programmatically so in this section
we'll be able to figure out how to
change the center in the view okay yeah
that's fine
oh I think it I need two smaller it's
harder that's a very projection
I can you try that harped on spear
projection yeah say that you're young oh
good sorry that's a good catch
nice fix that won't actually that should
work fine without the heart because did
you add the extra such a s file no okay
well you just uh s-sir scroll to the top
and resources and then you add the
extras yeah so the issue with that is it
wasn't added into our build Zoe just
active that's why you don't need the
heart
alright are you guys ready to move on to
the new section about modifying the map
programmatically cool so yeah we have a
method called set camera location and
zoom which we've already used and that's
where you could set the map to anywhere
you want so if you want to learn how to
set the map to your favorite city you
just need to find coordinates for it so
you could just type in Seattle
coordinates so really you just do your
favorite City Line coordinates and then
there's a nice site here called lat/long
I could just copy and paste this and
then paste it into here and we'll see
that the map Center will change to
whatever city or coordinates you set it
to so I'm from Seattle so I put the map
to here you also saw that you could
change the max pitch and then also the
rotation and the pitch so it's the max
pitch what it does is it sets the limit
for how far you could change it so as
you see 90 sometimes doesn't look the
best unless you're really zoomed in if
you're out here or the tiles start to
cut off so if you want to limit to what
the user can actually drag and change it
to you could set the angle there usually
45 is a good number to put it to so we
see if we do 45
we cannot go further down than 45
degrees and also the rotation you could
set here so we could sue maybe 120
degrees and you can see that the default
rotation has changed so you can set a
value there between 0 and 360 now let's
do something fun first of all I
recommend refreshing the github page
because we just found one small bug that
was fixed but if you refresh everything
will work fine so thanks for bearing
with us on that
to change the projection we're currently
at Mercator say if we want to try the
spear projection what we'll do is in the
constructor over map view for a
projection we'll copy and paste this
harp dot spear projection let's go up to
the top
severe projection and then we also need
to change the controls a little bit
since the globe used the different type
controls we're going to want to comment
out all the current harp map controls
code that includes also the UI elements
and then also the set rotation and Max
pitch angle and then we'll want to
replace it with the globe controls just
one thing to note for globe controls we
had to throw that in the extras file so
there's no need to put a harp in front
of it it's just globe controls and then
pass the map and then I'm going to
change the default view to zoom level 4
just so we get high to see the globe a
little bit better we refresh our new
globe Patrol's excuse me
and now we have a globe view it's a
little bit hard to see because we're in
the dark theme but the next section
we'll learn about changing theme and
you'll see how to change that and it'll
be a little bit more a little bit better
contrast on the globe so yeah just
remember to add in a new before the
globe controls
so we've created three themes you can
include into harp GL one is the main
earth colors and then we also have
reduced day and nights these themes are
called Berlin most because the the core
of the development for harp GL was done
in Berlin and we made some new themes
for that so in order to change the theme
what you could do is pass these URLs
into your map view constructor so if I
want to make the theme the Berlin base I
would just go ahead and paste it into
theme right up here so this theme
parameter also accepts relative URLs so
if you have a custom theme that you
create later on this workshop it doesn't
have to be an HTTP absolutely URL it
could just be theme JSON because you're
referencing the file inside your local
directory so go ahead and change the
theme a couple times I'll now make the
reduce day
I was reduced night reduced a
okay so do you guys want me to go over
the globe part again would that be
helpful okay I'll do that
so now we're back to the normal Mercator
flat view and we'll figure out how to do
the globe so if we go back to the github
page for the changing the maps
projection section the first thing we'll
want to do in the map constructor is add
an option for the projection so
projection is the Harpe sphere
projection so I'll copy this I'll go up
to the top of my index das file and I'll
add what I copied in there so basically
what we're setting here is the different
type of projection we want so by default
it goes to the Mercator projection which
is why if we wanted the sphere
projection we have to actually specify
that inside the constructor so that's
the first step the next thing we'll need
to do is actually get rid of the current
map controls because the map controls
only work with the Mercator projection
so inside the code that you copy and
paste in the very first step of getting
the map up and running we can just go
ahead and comment this out so notice I'm
commenting out the harp top map controls
basically because the pointer events for
interacting with the flat map are
slightly different than the globe and
I'm also just removing the map controls
UI from the side so since I deleted
those I now need to add different
controls for the globe which I have
right here so conce controls equals new
globe controls map I want to copy and
paste this and we also made it another
slight modification of the workshop just
two minutes ago
make sure to add new in front of globe
controls yeah
yes so if some of you guys are having
issues with the importing of glow
controls that is coming from the extras
Jas file so we had to throw that in last
minute due to a small bug that's also
why it doesn't have the harp dot globe
controls in there as well so you could
see if you open up extras jes glow
controls is right here so if you maybe
get an error cannot find glow controls
make sure that you have extras jot J s
imported into your HTML then once I have
that band running I can refresh my page
and will see the globe is working
any questions over here I can help with
yeah those are those aren't warnings or
errors that's just what's printed out so
no need to worry about those it's
working fine
this is barrel zoom out a lot yeah or
you could go back to your code and set
the zoom level to maybe four yep so you
got it working
nice hey how can I help
hi fields are not currently supported
government owns not defined so can you
show me your code editor please ah and
then you got extras yes oh yeah get rid
of the Harpe dot map controls just got
out that should fix it maybe do a hard
cash reset when you refresh
fields are not currently supported I
think it's maybe have an error with the
class inside the extra yes syntax do you
have a different browser maybe but
that's my guess is that a Firefox's are
reading the class because it's a es2015
syntax or something and there you go
okay that's exactly what it was I think
oh sorry about that
hi square projection is not defined
let's go back to your code
oh it's harps fear projection so right
in front of sphere projection right
there type harp har P dot and then save
that well and that should work perfect
so you want to zoom out a lot to
actually see the globe nice it's working
oh you guys doing okay over here
EXI game oh I'm sorry scroll to the very
top of this repo okay and it's in the
resources file okay yeah sorry that was
a little confusing yeah that's good yeah
for those of you we've already got the
globe running try to maybe change the
map theme and such play around with that
and we'll resume in a minute or so
hey unexpected token I'm so interesting
let's take a look you're extras at Jas
file this is exercise
I think this oh I think what happened is
you downloaded the github HTML instead
of yeah you guys doing okay over here
okay that should work of any questions
over here I could help with perfect
you guys following me everywhere I go
the what the theme yeah so to change the
theme well first of all we have three
default themes you could use base reduce
day and night
so we have links to all three of those
files right here if you click on them
they're all JSON files and you could set
the theme in the constructor so if I
want to do the reduced day I could copy
this link and then go into my
constructor and this theme parameter
right here I can copy and paste the
absolute URL to it so I'll set it to
dark
I'm sorry night here I don't know yeah
it is night
and then I could go to my web app just
refresh and you'll see that it's changed
to dark so you could change the theme in
the map view constructor there's also
the option to set the theme
programmatically later on outside the
constructor and you could just copy and
paste this code to do it as well it's
right below the three different maps on
the github page okay for this next step
let's do something fun let's add a
rotating camera around the map to create
an effect like this where the maps
rotating automatically so to do so it's
pretty simple just copy and paste a
couple lines of code but we'll be using
is a method called map dot look at it's
very similar to set camera geolocation
zoom however this time you can pass it
more than just the zoom level and
coordinates you could also pass it the
option either tilt and the rotation
so I'll copy and paste this into my
index J yes yes that's actually a great
point so if we're gonna do the rotation
we should actually move away from the
globe so we'll go back to the map
controls so to do so we're gonna get rid
of this projection in the constructor
and then add our map controls back to
the map and get rid of the globe
controls so this way we're going to go
back to the flat map so make sure to go
to the flat map if you want to do the
animation that we're about to do
so for the rotation code
we're basically waiting for a map event
saying that the map has rendered and
that means we want to then fire off the
rotation so every time it renders we're
going to want to update the rotation so
the azimuth right here and then we'll
use a piece of code that just begins the
animation with map begin animation so if
we go back and refresh our screen will
see the rotating view of Singapore I'm
actually to go back and update the theme
to the base style just so there's a
little bit more contrast on the
buildings
there we go so this is a pretty fun view
do you have your map set up very
game-like and you don't have to set it
to the Singapore coordinates you could
also set the rotation to whatever city
you come from or your favorite city as
well
so feel free to play around with the
rotation the center and such for like
five or so minutes and then we'll resume
on to the next section any questions yes
all right
yeah infinite so basically if you look
at the code every time the map renders
which is we see multiple times per
second or adding some of the angle here
so as long as the map is rendering which
it always will be
it will continue you could so you could
say maybe do like a while loop that's
adding up and then oh so yeah you could
use a set timeout a set interval a while
loop really any other sort of like
design yes okay correct I hate any I
could help with over here how like why
what exactly this is yes so that's a
myth is basically the angle between 0
and 360 mm-hmm and so we have this event
here called render and that's we see
firing multiple times per second and
every time it's rendering we're
basically adding a little bit to the
angle that's why it's changing so yeah
if you want to increase the basically
the velocity you would just add a higher
angler or something like that and then
if you want to make it slower just make
it like 0.1 or something like that okay
oh my god that's gonna go crazy
yeah because yeah because 360 right oh
my god this is gonna make me say guy
that just like motion sickness oh
actually not that much yeah I guess
think about I guess if it's between 0
and 180 that's there things might do
yeah I just wanted to go
yeah I've nowhere nice I wonder why
beautiful you sit there probably I can't
handle it what angle did you set 179 no
three not good plus yeah I don't know
interesting thank you yeah no where's
anything I could help with over here
yes we even send it to three makes it go
super fast and yeah five is way too much
I think
you guys having fun cool
alright are you guys ready to move on to
the next section
cool so now that we've got the map set
up you've learned how to rotate the
camera change the theme to adult a
default themes as well as set the center
in the pitch and such let's do something
fun which is styling the base map
so since harp GL is a vector render you
could really go crazy with styling the
map and do any of those style rules that
you want that we kind of talked about in
the beginning like see for example I
just made all the buildings green and
yellow the roads purple I mean yes it's
ugly as hell but it's kind of fun to
just be able to create this type of
stuff so we have a JSON editor that you
could do to edit these Styles right here
in the section 3 styling a base map
you'll see a link to here Maps github io
/ harp - map - editor you go ahead and
click on this and you can think of this
kind of as an interactive prototype
environment for styling maps yes it is
all in code technically just JSON
there's not really a UI to be changing
the colors but still it's nice because
you could actually see the changes live
in the screen to the right without
having to refresh your page or anything
so what we have here are all the
different style rules up here we kind of
have some some Global's around lights
and fogs and textiles and such but down
at around line 79 you actually see some
of the Styles it's the same syntax we
talked about in beginning so say for
example if you want to see the peers you
could actually change the color of the
peers and such and this style file might
be a little bit overwhelming because
there's a couple thousand lines long
that's because we have every single map
element inside of here so really the
main things that you might want to edit
would be say like the earth background
you could search for earth in here you
might want to also change water so we
could change the fill to maybe just
yellow my goal right here is to make the
ugliest map possible let's see what I
could do so yellow water that's it's
kind of crazy right now let's change the
earth to maybe white background I cannot
see any reason why earth isn't working
oh that see I'm editing the text here I
see I see
I'm so sure of the island will affect
maybe this is just removed remove the
whole condition yes they are in contact
yeah now these are both texts actually
what is the background inflator take the
in this case you need to do filmography
the background what it does this land
yeah there we go
yeah so earth is actually just the
background it's not the land land is
actually called land and we actually
have a different couple different types
of land like urban in parkland but
actually white does not look too good I
think I'm gonna go back to the previous
color but a fun one to change and
customize especially in the context of
the 3d engine are buildings so if you
actually scroll down to the very bottom
you'll see building geometry its line
1800 and this is where you could start
changing some of the things for
buildings so we could do
let's do background of blue for a
building you could see now we have the
blue background with the teal outline
but maybe let's make this a red outline
yeah this is pretty ugly so far and then
you could also style roads roads are
generally classified into three
high-level categories of primary
secondary and tertiary so if I want to
do primary roads I'm gonna search for
primary in here and then you could
change the color what colors have I not
used
let's do green yep and then you can see
some of the highways are now green now
I'm gonna search for secondary make the
secondary colors white give some
contrast to that there you go
and then for the third tier of roads
tertiary any colors you guys want to see
me add any suggestions do we have a
question from the audience from Nina
what color purple nice
yeah so there's a lot going on with this
map anyway
knock yourself out with the colors there
but once you're done creating this
hideous tile or maybe some of you guys
have created a beautiful style you could
actually click this download button in
the middle sidebar so I'll download that
file by default it went to my downloads
but what I could do is actually drag
that into my folder directory so mine is
called heart map I'm gonna rename it
just themed JSON instead of theme space
parentheses one and then I could go back
to my code and then inside the theme
option right here instead of doing the
absolute URL to the here map theme I
could just do theme dot JSON because I'm
referencing the local file that I just
downloaded from the heart editor and
when I go to my map and I refresh you're
gonna see this hideous theme in your own
map so we'll fix the tilt a little bit
so just to repeat that process in case
anyone missed it inside the heart map
editor you see this button right here
it's the download the down arrow you can
click on that and then it will basically
download this JSON file in the left hand
side and then you can put that inside
your project directory and then
reference it in the map view constructor
just set the theme
any questions over here
don't with a lesson Angela steps over I
mean did it sit for four to two today uh
yeah did you put the dancing guy no I
okay yeah if you did all the steps
you've completed the workshop so he want
your you're free to leave or if you have
any other questions I'd be happy to help
it's awesome
I'm more of a good golfer golfer
convicted cocaine radiation yeah and get
to know open
the different API session yeah well I'm
glad you enjoyed it
you're gonna put it into any projects
you've been working on recently look
market but okay awesome
yeah well thanks for attending cool
thanks nice to meet you what was your
name no Dylan hi
this time look into that the values of
the Phoenicians but you can see the
specification of exactly work the
enticing which one you know what you
wanted to do before you change the
background here is gonna little more
complicated
yeah
all right I hope you all are having fun
with the map styles and knocking
yourself out creating some crazy styles
let's move on to the next section of
adding data to the map so these maps are
really fun and awesome making the colors
all pretty and stuff but we could
actually add some utility to them and
create some data visualizations of
geographic data so before we move on to
the next section I'm just going to go
ahead and disable this animation that we
have running most of because it doesn't
let you control the map if it's
currently running and then I'm also
going to set my zoom level just
something a little bit further down so
we could actually see Singapore so
basically just going to reset my map hmm
to the Singapore coordinates as well now
it's looking a little bit better to
where we had the map before
so the first exercise we'll do is add
some geo JSON to the map and we'll be
adding static geo JSON so it's not gonna
be coming from a server and it's not
going to be already be tiled we will
simply just be adding a geo JSON file we
have locally on our machine onto the map
and so inside the resources directory of
this repository we have a file in here
called wireless - hotspots geo JSON so
what this is is a basically a list of
all the public hotspots for Wi-Fi
throughout Singapore and so I'll go
ahead and just download this file so
download and then save page as and then
wireless - hotspots geo JSON by default
github is putting a dot txt to the end
of the file you want to go ahead and
remove that so the file extension is geo
JSON and I'm going to want to save that
into my project directory so I could go
back to my vs code editor and then
actually take a look at the data in here
it's geo JSON the same as what we
learned earlier in this workshop of you
see the properties which has some HTML
in here as a string but then also near
the end as we scroll past this you'll
actually see the geometry in here so we
see that it's type point and then we
have the coordinates right here so
basically giving us the information of
where to put the stott on the map now
I'll go back to the readme file where
I'll copy some of the code
so what would be doing here is creating
a network request using the fetch
function to the wireless hotspots Gio
JSON file just to make sure that works
let's do a console log of the data just
make sure we see it over here yep so it
looks like that request is successful we
see all the different features in here
from the file the properties and such so
the first thing I want to do is create a
Geo JSON data provider so you could use
the function Harvey Oh JSON data
provider pass it the name which will be
wireless - hotspots and then you also
want to pass it the variable of the data
so I just named it data then once you've
created the geo JSON data provider
you'll want to create a geo JSON data
source so with this you also pass the
two parameters the data provider we just
created so geo JSON data provider and
then wireless hotspots so this code will
technically add it to the map actually
excuse me we need to do one more one
more function map add data source geo
JSON data source but we need to do one
more thing once it's added to the map we
need to apply the styles in order for
the data to show so we could add it to
the map but if there's no style is
provided to the map it won't have
anything to show the data it would just
be blank objects on the map so what
we're doing is passing one of these
style objects these are the same style
objects that are within the theme not
JSON file except or just to knit with
under JavaScript now so we're saying
when geo make sure that geometry type is
a point we're gonna want to use the
circles technique and then style it this
color then once we've created that
object we'll want to pass it to the geo
JSON data source using the function set
style set and then we will call a map
update
so once we have that pace in here we can
go back to our map refresh and although
we have a ton of different colors on the
map right now you can see these kind of
light green highlighter colors or all
the goj sun points that we added so
every time you see a teal sorry not teal
highlighter color these are the wireless
hotspots with in Singapore and say if I
wanted to change the color of those
hotspots
I could edit it right here in my
JavaScript so we can do white - this
time for a little bit more contrast that
definitely looks a little bit better and
so if your map is not showing the data
or if you're not within Singapore you
should make sure to set your coordinates
back to Singapore so you'll be able to
actually see the data on the map
how you doing over here awesome
well let me know if there's something I
could help with any questions over here
so are you developing on an iPad yeah
that's cool you have Windows running on
here that's awesome
time to change the what oh the tilt so
you do with your mouth like that but to
do with the code go back to your vs code
I scroll up and you want to do a set
rotation so 50 is the current set so you
could do maybe just zero if you want to
top down view there you go
any questions over here
so you guys just learned how to add
static geo JSON from a file onto the map
but there's also different types of data
sources you could add such as tiled data
sources from servers so we have another
product called here XYZ which basically
does tiled data sources for you which
that means is when you have large data
sets you want to actually divide it up
into squares across the world basically
what this means is you don't have to
load all the data at once say if you had
a 10 gigabyte file of the earth you
really don't want to only want to render
the file that you're seeing in the
viewport so say for example if we were
looking at Singapore what exercise you
would do is actually query the data just
for your viewport so that's basically
what a tile that data source is so in
this next exercise we're gonna actually
want to add a tiled data source and to
do so we've already set up a data source
for you it's going to be global
railroads all across the world and to do
this you'll want to actually use another
HAARP onb data source so right here in
the section adding tiled geo JSON from
server I want to copy and paste this
global Rail road's variable
and what this is is the base URL to this
data set we see the unique identifier
right here you don't really have to
think too much about this API endpoint
this is just where the data is stored
however something that is important is
this authentication code previously when
you added the base map data when you
created the map you passed your own
authentication code it's important to
use this saw tendon creation code
provided in the code because that
basically gives you access to the data
set do not put your own authentication
code inside of here
so once I've created the omv data source
I then want to add it to the map so I'll
be using the same syntax that I did
before for the static goj Sun basically
instead of referencing a file that I've
added to my site I'm now referencing
this tiled data source from a server so
I'll do the same function map add data
source but this time I'm just doing
global railroads instead of the Geo JSON
data source and then I'm attaching a
style to it
this time the global railroads are lines
set of points so I have when geometry
type is line we're gonna want to use
this technique solid line with this
color and then it's always going to be
one pixel wide so beforehand and you
could also do options for circles or
lines in meters the difference with one
pixel is that the size will say constant
no matter what zoom you're at next we'll
attach the style set to the global
railroads and then we'll update the map
also because this is a global data set
I'm gonna want to change my zoom level
to maybe say four or five so I could see
the entire data set
and also fix this rotation here we go so
it does take a little bit longer because
it's a much larger service and file but
you now should see red lines pop up all
over the globe you see India has a lot
Europe is pretty populated as well these
are all the railroads in the entire
world you actually see these are loading
kind of square by square those are the
tiles I was just mentioning so when the
viewport sees that we are looking at
this it's not going to load up this tile
of the data set
so this is actually a pretty bit pretty
data visualization just lines all over
the place although I don't know if the
red looks too good with my teal
background
yeah of course yeah so we didn't go too
much into detail on the XYZ part that's
basically a back-end server that's
taking the data when you upload it
basically dividing up two tiles all over
the globe and so what harp GL is doing
is when you add that data source
it takes basically the viewport
coordinates that you're looking at so
same Singapore and taking those
coordinates and also the zoom level and
it's sending a query back to the server
to only ask for that data that way
you're not loading everything at once
but I guess it's a little bit it's
different when you look at the world
because we're days calling all the tiles
but it's a little bit more efficient if
you're just loading a smaller zoom level
area yeah so that's another product it's
secondly open source as well you can
find that in github and such but we're
just not going into too much detail
we're mostly just doing the
visualization side of thing but if you
know a lot of geospatial data
engineering that's actually a very
helpful tool so I believe the API I'm
sorry the endpoint is like explored
xyz.com so just type in here X Y Z you
get some more information on the product
and they also have a like a map styling
studio you can do pretty much the same
things as this but all with a UI so you
don't have to actually code it so pros
and cons obviously with heart GL since
you can code with it you could really
get any Styles really there's no limits
on what you could do whereas the UI it's
a little bit more basic for non coders
where there's a little bit limitations
on it so it really depends on like what
type of project you're doing
how's it going over here everyone's
excited
awesome so our map is looking great by
now when we put all the railroad colors
and lines on here so we're not colors
just lines but there's also a concept
called data-driven styling which you
basically style the data based on
different properties so right now all
the lines are just one color because
they're all the different railroads in
here but say if we wanted to see the
different railroads that are not active
or that are currently shut down what we
could do is take the property from the
Geo JSON and the tiles that says
railroads are not active or their
clothes and such and apply different
colors to those that way we'd get a mix
of maybe red lines for active railroads
and then a different color for railroads
that are closed savory or some sort of
data analyst and we wanted to see which
countries had closed railroads and stuff
like that so you could apply different
styling rules to the properties of the
data to do so we don't have to change
any of the code for adding the data
source and such all we have to do is
change the style rules that we apply so
I'm going to go to the code block where
I added a style
I'm going to replace it right here just
delete that with two new style objects
previously we had when geometry type
equals a line we apply a rule but now
we're adding something else we're gonna
say when geometry type is a line and
property status is open so what this
properties and status is is if we go
back to the Geo JSON this is just an
example of how it looks we see in
properties there is a key and value pair
that says status is open so we want to
select that data and apply this color
the five zero e 3 C 2 then we also have
when properties are either closed or we
don't know so we'll assume those are
are closed we could then apply a
different color we can do this d630 six
so basically we're splitting the data
into two different buckets here open or
closed or possibly unknown so we could
save that file go back to our web app
let it load and the colors that I set is
green or teal equals active and then red
is closed so you could see there's some
red lines that are now popping up in
South America and also Africa that means
that the railroads are closed so you
could apply these techniques to really
any dataset to differentiate between
different properties say for the
Singapore dataset we could have done
maybe the size of the circle depending
on how many devices they can handle at
once and such really any sort of
property in the data quantitative or
qualitative you could add to the styling
rules on the map
unless you record this
oh I probably feel good standing in
front of it just the back your shirt
that's fine Hey
oh how to remove them yeah so you do
that in your theme file so right now you
are see you're calling I think you can't
edit what you do is you would open that
up inside the map to be editor yeah and
then I mean so what I did is yeah so
there's a quick little hacky you do
instead of deleting all the text what
you do is just download this file and it
basically this has dependencies on other
resource files like font files and icons
so if you download that and you just
added your theme the fonts or the text
won't show up because the attached fonts
aren't available in the same way that
the URL would have them
all right any questions on the data
driven styles are you all ready to move
it on to 3d objects yeah there we go
that's the excitement I like to see cool
so because harp GL is built on a popular
3d web library called 3j s you're
actually able to call all the api's that
you would a 3j s right inside a harp as
well so for a little bit more
information on 3j s you could click on
their site they have a lot of cool
examples of things you could do with 3j
s it's a fun little cattle gallery to
look through but the first exercise
we'll be doing is adding a simple cube
to the map something just like this this
isn't really a geographic object or
anything like this or just simply
creating a 3d cube with the three jsapi
s and then adding it to the map so what
I'll do is copy this go to my index J s
and this is all three J s code which I'm
not exactly too familiar with but we'll
be creating the geometry so size 100 on
all the edges and then adding some
material which will simply just be a
pink color and then creating the cube
with the geometry and material we're
also doing a property called render
order this is basically the Z and X
where all the objects on the map just to
make sure this shows up above buildings
and roads and such next will be assigned
in a Geo position and then we will be
adding it to the map with map map
anchors adds cube so the logic I want to
set up is that wherever I click on the
map I want to be able to add a cube so
we'll be adding an event listener
I just canvas start on click
so basically when the map canvas is
clicked we're gonna want to create this
object and add it to the map so since
I'm already zoomed out I'm pretty far
because I was showing the whole world
and we're gonna be creating a pretty
small cube before I execute this code
I'm gonna want to change my zoom level
to something a little bit larger so we
could actually see the cube so I'm gonna
go back to maybe 16 or 17 I'll go and
refresh my page I'm back to Singapore
and now whenever I click we'll see a
cube is popping up and it's a nice 3d
cube basically the event listener is
saying when clicked I want to view the
coordinates of the click and I'm going
to assign those coordinates to the cube
position and then I'm gonna add it to
the map server that you could honestly
create like a game of checkers here if
you wanted to by assigning the different
colors on alternate clicks and such or
you could also make massive cubes by
changing the box geometry size let's
increase it by 100 times you see if we
clicked on it we basically crush the
entire city on accident
yes we have quite the ridiculous map
going on here sealed water cubes
everywhere railroad showing and still
wireless hotspots as well as you see you
could really go crazy with these maps if
you want to
all right so now that we added the cube
the cubes a little boring get to MIT how
about we add a dancing 3d man like this
that's a little bit more exciting of a
3d object huh so we created the previous
cube just programmatically using the
three jsap eyes but this time we're
going to be importing an object into our
map so if we go into the resources file
of this repository well want to download
this dancing FBX this is a 3d object
so I'll click download and then I'll go
ahead and move it into my project folder
and I'm going to get rid of the
parentheses one so before we proceed
just make sure you've downloaded this
dancing FBX 3d object into your project
directory and it's available inside the
resources folder
so in order to add this to the map I'll
go ahead and copy and paste the code
added there we're going to be using a 3G
is what it's called an FBX loader so
this is basically making a network
request to get this file
dancing FBX and then basically parsing
it so we could use it in our 3d scene
we'll be doing some optimum actions like
setting the render order so that it's
high up on the map and it's not behind
anything then also doing it's like
setting the scale to make it as large as
we want and then just set in a name to
it so we can name it human but you can
name it whatever you want and then also
we're going to set the geo position so
we're just going to set it somewhere in
Singapore using the HAARP geo
coordinates API and then finally we will
do the same thing as we did before map
map anchors got add object so this will
add it to the map but because we have an
animated object we also need to make an
animate so add a little bit more code
we'll be doing the same event listener
as before for the map rotation actually
no it's not the same one it's it's
similar though map view event name start
render and then basically if the object
is loaded we're gonna want to set it to
animate so once we pasted this code we
can go back to our map and then we
should have our dancing man somewhere
here he is he's over in the water so
here he is he's dancing right next to
the Marina Bay Sands I'm actually gonna
set my max pitch to something a little
bit higher 90 so we get a better angle
there he is so he's having fun dancing
away he loves just comp so much that
he's expressing his happiness so this is
just an example object that we found on
the three J s site you could really do
this with any three J s object that you
have so if you have some other fun
dancing people or really something like
a spaceship taking off you could easily
add this to the map using the same code
as before
so any questions on the dancing person
like help with
all right everybody so we're almost done
with the workshop that was second to
last final activity so you guys have all
made some pretty cool maps by now you've
dancing people on them you have cubes
all over the place where are those
hotspots real roads and probably really
strange watercolor just like mine so I'm
encourage you to actually share these
maps with us from the workshop so since
we have the simple API your files are
now usually just index.html index J yes
any other dancing person your theme we
recommend you guys create a new github
repository and set up github pages so
you could actually create a URL to your
project then feel free to tweet at us we
are at here dev and we'll be retweeting
some of our favorite maps exactly a good
way to be able to show your friends and
family what you did at Jas comp you'd
say hey I made this awesome 3d map with
some really strange colors and dancing
people on top definitely a good thing to
show people
so do you all know how to make a github
pages website or should I go through
that I think I'll go ahead and do that
so to create a github pages account you
could go to github.com and then go to
your in the top right see little plus
click new repository I'm gonna say I'm
gonna title this my awesome map and the
description would be made with aid
during the RPL workshop click create a
repository and I'm going to go back to
my command line inside the directory my
project is and I'm going to create a new
git repository so git init and then I'm
going to add everything in here so get
add dot and then get commit - M first
commit of my awesome map then I want to
add the remotes of this github page
repository and then push everything with
git push origin master so if we give it
a sec we'll see that all the files have
popped up in here even my DS store that
shouldn't be committed and then inside
the Settings tab
you could go scroll down until you see
github pages and then you'll set the
source to master branch that will save
automatically and the page will take one
or two minutes to build so we'll check
back then and we'll see how the websites
looking but the URL will be your github
username so - Dee Babs github yo and
then the name of the repository so mine
is called my - awesome - map
oh and it's already built and we'll see
the same map we had as before say I
think we're just a little bit zoomed in
we have some errors there there we go
the map was just wasn't loaded on the
first try and now we have a shareable
link to the map we just built so you go
ahead and tweet that we are on Twitter
at here dev so thank you all for
attending this workshop we hope you've
had fun and learned a lot about harp gl
so far you've learned how to create a
new harp chill application from scratch
you've learned how to customize the
theme add data to the map as well as
style that data with data-driven styling
and then you've also learned how to add
3d objects to the map so if you have any
feedback on the workshop or on harp CL
we're always looking for improvement you
could fill out this google form we have
set up the team will reviewing
everything or you could also create an
issue on the harp shield github
repository so thank you very much and
feel free to stick around as long as you
want and continue working on the maps
and we'll be continuing to provide
support or answering any questions
[Applause]